hello
good
day I'm doing a little bit better
still a little bit sickish but
it's slowly getting better I think I
just had a flu or
something but uh yeah how are all of you
doing
did I block it correctly
nope how about
now H we can work with this I
think
no there we
go Angelic Zelda doing okay off to off
of work today oh you're you have a free
day that's
great still does that black screen
thingy I don't know
why um I was again not paying attention
I was reading chat so I have no idea
what actually
changed I think something
opened I really need to pay attention
when I
play I think Nintendo Direct is coming
soon yeah I sources say next week I
believe oh God I forgot we are in a bad
spot I have no more
small food items to consume and I don't
want to waste
these and I'm missing one quarter of a
heart so one sh I'm going to get get one
shot by everything pretty
much but
yeah 20 million copies sold yeah I think
that's a nice a nice number I think bre
Wild is at like
33 or 31k U 31
mil 31k would be very
tragic uh Happy Wednesday from C Canada
same to you from the
Netherlands is this the new new Zelda
DLC oh I only
wish uh can someone help me out for a
moment I I didn't check what what
changed after I activated the the light
thing down
there oh you're sick too Clifford that
that that sucks hope you get better
soon it's really uh like a lot of people
are coming down with stuff now
huh I was supposed to go out to dinner
with uh Dr
Wy not too long ago and he was also uh
he had to cancel last minute because he
was
sick so
yeah it
sucks AB James says the Nintendo Direct
is likely going to be a partner showcase
and
usually the February January sometimes
direct is usually not a partner
showcase like it's kind of like a
tradition that they always
do I should Farm these These are really
powerful for for the final boss I
think and that's all she
Road Dr Wy from Mega Man no the Zelda
theorist Dr Wy
but I like the uh like the
idea uh but yeah something in this room
changed after I activated the light
thingy I just don't know
what did this open and now I can shine
this here I think that's what it is so
that means I have
to stop this from
closing there we
go and now we
just see if we can aim this in the right
spot
what and there we
go Beth says glad you're better my whole
family just got over Co oh God that that
that's really bad every time you I'm I
keep getting reminded like yeah it's
still a thing it still
exists Co did not not just magically go
away it's not as aggressive as it was in
the beginning like these new variants
are much more mild which is how it
usually tends to
happen that's normal so
yeah but I'm glad you and your family
are
better uh let's see do we have any
more
there's one
more see this is ground
floor one two three four so it's on
three am I on
three
uh think I
am it's not that one no wait I'm not on
three I'm on four so one
[Music]
down so it's on this floor well it
should be one of these
rooms so I guess this is
two yeah this is
two um
[Music]
um I think we already activated that
one wavery says Ah a perfect
accompaniment accomp oh I've never said
that word before in my whole life to my
Minecrafting
downtime good day to you
too
accompanyment
uh let's
see have I been in there yeah that's how
you open this
door we definitely have been
here oh thank God the robots are not
back yeah this is where this one was uh
I think we can just maybe phase to the
next room let's see it's
there uh uh uh uh
yeah there's like a Stairway here so I
guess it is this
one but how however will we get light
down
here you just reminded me of the
Minecraft streams oh yeah I haven't done
a Minecraft stream in a long time I
haven't played Minecraft in
general let's see this
one I think that one is aimed straight
at that thing over
there there we
go just a little bit of spatial
reasoning
which translates to I'm an
idiot uh okay there's
a thingy over here where's reu I need
you can I already just destroy it yeah I
can oh but the did
spawn oh
man this is going to be rough no link
don't climb
it let's see oh my God they're up there
on this I'm going to get one shot for
sure that's
one
and my bow broke I think we do have
enough bows though
yeah we do I'm just going to play
chicken with them because I really do
not want to get one
shot I'm going to hit him with a zonai
core
yeah
you distract them regi oh my God it's
coming for
me
no big Z core
go another
one
oh it's already
dead
nope I do not want anything to do with
you uhoh
uhoh oh he's got his shield up nice job
reu
because everything pretty much one shots
me I just I'm just going to rely on
arrows mostly because that at least then
I don't have to get
close
uh Blair daro says Dutch and danish
accents sound very similar in
English you mean when people talk
Dutch or Danish it sounds the same or
you mean when they speak English it
sounds the
same like we have the same English
accent cuz danish when I hear Danish
people talk it sounds like they're
talking a like it kind of sounds like
they're talking Dutch but like
unintelligibly there's there's little
words in there that are very similar or
even just the same
so it's it's very
weird oh this the same bow
actually no REO I I did not tell you to
do
that
oh uh let's see should be up here
somewhere oh come on can I grab
this but yeah I am pretty excited for uh
for the
direct I hope uh they will show
something
good
let me just take a gander up here real
quick before I do anything in the
room don't waste your Zone ey
[Music]
balls
uh oh I
guess I can either just use one of these
platforms
to get here or I just use a balloon I
just strap a a mirror to
it there are mirrors here right yeah
let's see if that works actually I'm I'm
curious it's probably not how you're
supposed to do it
but I mean it's my my playthrough I can
do whatever I want
see if this
works oh
[Music]
Arrow do I have wood though no I do
not well there goes my
plan what if I strap a torch to it do I
have
anything that can light fire to it yeah
well one I get one
shot this is probably such a convoluted
way to do
this and it went it just went right
through I'll just light it with the
other torch
then
uh oh broke the
mirror can I
take let's see if this
works
yeah okay wait wait no
no no
wait
okay did it
work no it went too
high and now it's
spinning also tears of the Kingdom
wasn't originally DLC for not yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
absolutely oh it ran out of
battery what why do people want a third
game in the same Hyrule that sounds
terrible in the same Hyrule yeah if it's
in a in a different completely different
continent then sure yeah I'm down for
it
well I cannot reach that oh wait I
can
there's probably a way easier solution
to this but I'm once I commit to it I
just want to keep it going just if only
for the sake of
humor let's R
you oh there she is just manifests out
of
nowhere it's almost boss time and I'm
going to get my ass
kicked all right we've charged all of
the B light that up the me
in all right so I guess what we'll
do I think I'm going to stock up on some
arrows before we head to the fight I
don't have I
have2 so I don't have a lot to work with
but I can sell some rubies and uh some
other stuff
so uh world map that's
X we'll just go to gudo town stock up on
some arrows maybe cook some food if we
can I have $2 $2 in my
pocket because we are going to need all
the food that we can get
because everything is going to just take
all my hearts I just have to make sure I
always keep my hearts
up cuz I don't think anything can
oneshot you as long as you have Full
[Music]
Hearts
I think this one has arrows in
it oh I already took them I
guess give me arrows oh wait first sell
me stuff or buy my stuff I should
say I'm not interested in your
granddaughters buy for me
oh wait I have seven of these I can just
sell all of them I don't need topaz or
opal gut get much shorter the older they
get yeah they sure
do all of them that's
two I think I still had a ruby here
somewhere too oh did I already sell
it yes I
did but at least we have 300 more than
$300
now so I
guess we need to go shopping for for
some food somewhere because they don't
sell food
here I could use some some of these
though 70 rupees jeez this economy
man no not
those all
right do they have food food here do you
have
food that's not
enough o they have mushrooms
[Music]
here damn she is happy to sell me
stuff
oh whoever voiced her really was feeling
it when you buy
something so we are down to $78 now I
think they also have some food at the
bazaar I want the vendor in my local
store to do that every time I buy
something actually I'm heading to the
market
tomorrow to buy some veggies and some
other
stuff I think she only has seared steak
and all that kind of stuff yeah it's at
least it's
something I'm practically giving these
away well give them to me then for free
I'm I'm saving the world
[Music]
here uh can I sell anything else
KO says the guda desert definitely got
the best love and detail changes
compared to all the other regions even
with the eight heroin thing which I
think was a result of ignoring the past
by
rule I don't know there's something
about the desert in general that I
really like it's not for everyone maybe
but
I've got way too many of
these can sell at least
half maybe more because I don't really
have the weapons to fuse them
[Music]
too uh anything can why can I not sell
these I don't need
them can always mine for some more
stuff I guess
I just realized we haven't been to the
depths at all
yet or else I will just mine for some
zonite give me all your
[Music]
food okay let's see we have 69 arrows
nice
uh I think we need a bunch more arrows
though cuz I'm going to rely on arrows
mostly arrows are going to be so
important during this fight
nice uh
yeah oh wait we don't have money
uh I guess we can mine for some stuff
real
quick cuz if I run out of arrows I'm
screwed during that
fight wolf Knight says I hope this
franchise will have a themed land in
Universal Studio possibly Florida ah
when epic epic universe is
finished well we already got a Mario
themed park right in
Japan if I recall
correctly
I don't think I have any clothing that
protects me against
heat but we are going to need some
stuff well our job is
done uh uh uh uh uh how do we even get
up
here oh wait this ledge seems like I
could be
it could be able to climb it with one
stamina but yeah Zelda theme part theme
park would be
nice
but yeah the gr the desert in general is
one of my favorite areas even in bre
wild I already liked it there's
something about the
atmosphere probably going to start
taking damage soon
because quite
warm there should be some good ore
deposits here
somewhere yeah okay it's already
starting yeah I'm taking
damage this might not be the best place
to go mine for stuff maybe we go to
Fen I think there's a few or deposits
there too
can't you use sideon against you just
use the bubble
thingy I
guess that's actually I've never used
that as a way to keep
cool but that is smart
yeah
let's go to the Zone I ruins for a
moment uh wait where am I I'm oh there's
Death Mountain so it's that
way don't think I'm going to get very
far
though having no stamina
sucks but I still refuse to do any
shrines
we are here to complete the story and
that's
it
we sidon has the most useless Sage
ability yeah cuz it's very specific for
very specific enemies
save me
weoo
okay uh this is not a great place to
be we got the wewo in the
house I have no idea where to go for or
deposits I usually just go to the desert
but we are not well equipped for
that is it me or are there less or
deposits in this game compared
to bre the
wild could just be
me
yeah sidon is a cool character but I
feel like they kind of they didn't
really do much with him here aside from
his own dungeon
area which I guess is the same for all
the sages
but not enough character
development the or is all in caves now
not outside it it seems oh that makes
sense yeah
yeah guess we're going to have to go
find a cave then oh then we can just go
to
hebra there's plenty of caves there some
of which I have not explored
yet cuz I don't know where all the caves
in faren are I know a couple but I think
those are more like those excavation
sites but yeah that you're you're
totally
right uh yeah there's like three C
here and I'm dressed for the cold at
least hello
angel how are you
doing we are in desperate need of money
that that's that's today's goal I guess
I'm going to fight the boss though
whether we we find it or
not but there's a
cave I think that's the cave where you
go to find
Tulin I know there's a bunch of or below
hyu
Castle there's not a lot here it seems
oh well at least we have
fish and mushrooms and
ore we struck gold well not gold but
it's probably just rocks yeah one opall
one
opall we
good getting [__]
Rich that is today's goal
yeah make some
dough there's nothing up here right no
oh I think this is the way back is it
no
no it is damn
it I thought we were
up good good thing I don't go caving in
real life because I would get stuck and
be one of those Missing 411 people who
just never they never see them
again oh there it
is hey luminous
Stones that's 20 bucks per
pop oh another ore
here some
Amber weird having Zelda and Harry
Potter next to each other theme landwise
I kind I guess it kind of
fits it's both
magic okay I'm not going to fight that
guy he's going to one shot me for
sure cuz it's a blue one what kind of
weapons do weapon does he
have well Tulin is like screw
that we are going going in
there well at least we have a a clear
passage
now got some more
flint and we broke our
Hammer uh oh we have to use a pine
cone which means I have to waste
arrows or wait I have Flint
right so oh I hear him coming he coming
oh Lord he
coming
wait
why let's see how effective these things
really are how much damage does this do
oh he's dead
damn
seeing the two castles side by side oh
yeah there's a place in Elden ring that
also really looks like
Hogwarts one of one of the
dungeons it's supposed to be like a
magical Academy so it's pretty much the
same
thing I guess you have to hit it with
something metal
if you want fire to
happen
uh let's
see pleas work
yeah is there any any
more
or I think I had like 400 bright Caps or
something so when
I whenever I got low on on health I
would just stuff away bright caps like a
maniac oh look there we go and there's a
bubble frog here
too
wait this does not do the thing oh well
that was a
waste
oh did you did I tell you to
weo I did not
as an immense fan of both Harry Potter
and Zelda I'm personally okay with that
yeah I am too you they have my
blessing uh uh I don't want to waste any
of these These are going to be good on
the bosses
and it's just rock salt anyway
H rock
salt we are really scraping the bottom
of the barrel aren't we just to get
money
oh these give these give give these give
you
Amber yeah I like how the Amber just
changed shape to be like a
spearhead magic how
convenient h i canot I'm not going to
shoot these they're
harmless
we
woo that was an illegal we
woo he was not supposed to do
that
fish free
fish they made it much harder to make
rupes tears the kingdom
really in tears of the kingdom it get
gets blocked by little there's like a
little heart shape thingy which blocks
like the final word of every sentence
it's very annoying you go go you could
go hunt and sell the cooked
meat we have some uh cooked meat I just
want to have some stuff that's like easy
to just gobble down whenever you're down
a few
hearts and just a couple of
mules I think we have most of what we
need
now just some more
arrows I want to have at least 100
arrows when we when we do
this should be another cave
here it's down there
somewhere or is that how we is that
where we came in I don't think
so no it's not this
one this guy just wants
stuff chill
shrooms how many chill shrooms do we
have have
four all right maybe he'll give give me
money I think he
does
no
don't oh my
God no stop
it put it
here there's no way it will slide down
yeah uh uh
destroy Fus
material so much easier than just using
a
w gamer 1288 says it took me an hour to
notice that large cut on my hand a large
cut on your hand it's
bleeding and for the pain to
start yeah sometimes it just happens
like the actual moment you get the wound
you you don't feel
it it's it's very very weird
I also had a pretty big wound on my hand
not too long
ago I was working on one of my painball
guns and I had to push this little pin
out and I pushed a little too hard lost
my grip and it just sheared off like a
whole part of my
fingernail like the corner of my my what
is it it's my middle finger still
there's still a pretty pretty big uh
black spot there right
now I bet 10 bucks you can beat GTO U
Queen gyto without taking damage just
kidding well you would probably win that
wager anyway because I am not that good
at this game like maybe if I play it
super super super safe there's an arrow
in the water can I get
it
no
come on
yeah I think that's my own arrow that I
just
shot give me
these is this
enough you didn't actually cross the
pond give me money
yeah
bucks and now we got 69 rupees
nice all right is there one more cave
here
somewhere this is the one we just
did there should be more inside that
cave by the way because I it doesn't
have a check
mark but
uh I think we can just go go to Lookout
Landing now to get some arrows I I
shouldn't put off this boss fight any
longer than I have I have to because I'm
going to I'm going to
die I'm going to try my best to do it in
one shot but I I cannot make that
promise especially not with the amount
of hearts and armor I have
that is to say
none I could upgrade my armor but I mean
this is turning into a challenge run
so they have arrows here right
yeah wait I'll buy them all oh that's
100 I I'll sell you some stuff first
then why do people not just give me the
stuff I need to save the
world I'm the hero of the
story I guess people still got to make a
living blood moon there's a blood moon
coming I hope
so a village attacked by
Pirates or just normal bins they didn't
even dress like dress them up like like
little Pirates like they did in Skyward
Sword at least there they wore actual
outfits you
know uh we got
one of
these we got this
oh yeah Amber that's another 60
bucks all
right got two of these three of these
that's not enough by the way I need more
Elemental stuff but I I guess we can
just use reu power for
that hey check how how do I pronounce
that last part
check
I'm doing good how about
you sorry I cannot pronounce your
name no that's not enough I don't want
to get rid of
that uh time to cook some
food so how many arrows do we have now
that's good enough I guess can always
find
more how much armor points does this
only three I think that's less than what
I'm currently wearing right oh it's
about the
same I guess the pants would be nice but
120 120 bucks that's steep
man let's
cook there's no blood moon right oh
there is you were right good
observation that means all the ore that
we just collected will be
back wait we can cook during the blood
moon it will have good effects right uh
where's the cooking thingy where is it
oh
there yeah it's already
starting
um
put some salt in there do we have salt y
yep we
do actually I shouldn't make these too
powerful because I only have five Hearts
so or
six right how many hearts
okay
uh like something like a Hardy truffle
won't do much I I could at least cook it
up I guess how much does it give you
normal only two yeah then I should cook
it at least it it'll give me extra
Hearts uh but not if I put it with these
I think because it's going to
override but I don't have anything else
to cook with oh
dilemas
dilemas I think those effects are just
going to cancel each other out
but oh well we don't have anything
else uh uh uh they did sell something
else
outside maybe I should screw the blood
moon
cooking
no
the coins are raking in infinite Coin
Block in Bowsers keep in Super Mario RPG
is nice oh I guess I missed some I I
haven't played it yet I'm I still have
to play it oh I can combine it with
apples with all the Gloom going on
everywhere oh wait it's gone
now I'll buy them all
[Music]
oh and it's
back when the glow of the Blood Stained
Moon shines upon the
land oh no I wonder if Zelda is
evil Hello
Elanor how are you
doing is Arrow your actual last name
if it is that's really
awesome uh yeah I should combine it with
apples yeah sorry Elanor I was sick I
wanted to
stream uh
earlier like on on Sunday but I was
coming down with something not so
great so I just chilled at home and do
nothing yeah I'm mostly better now still
a little bit
weakish not 100% but I'm I'm getting
there
oh heat resistance just what we
needed I don't think these have any or
do they yeah they have the glowy side
effect I guess we we can do one
more and we'll keep the rest just to
fill up those like quarter
Hearts doing nothing was probably the
best course of action there yeah
although I do not enjoy doing nothing at
least not
always uh I can get rid of this thing
now now that we're not farming for stuff
anymore and I can fuse that to something
better what do we have to fuse
with I guess this one is more powerful
yeah that's decent so we got
24 H these are rather weak but
when we get desperate
enough I think we can get some more
swords
upstairs even when I say I'm not going
to do anything I always still end up
doing
[Music]
something yeah just give
him give him to me
give me it give me this
one oh I don't have room how does he
know
that can you see into my
pockets
I don't need the other two
uh
oh all the powers look the
[Music]
same there we go oh only 28 so I guess
we'll just start with the strongest one
uh well not the strongest
but actually yeah why
not do we need to do anything Shield
wise what's a good combination to do
when it comes
to he has the lens of Truth
yeah is there anything like Shield wise
that is a good idea to
fuse aside from Zone I deser devices
because I don't have a whole lot of them
well actually as a flame emitter would
be a good idea against Gip
those let's just do that
then although I don't really have that
much battery
but oh
well
are you expecting news about Zelda at
the next Nintendo Direct if it is it's
probably going to be either about the
movie or maybe a 2d Zelda
or like a a port or remake probably like
a
port but I don't expect more than that
to be honest it's uh it's not been that
long since this game released so usually
they take a bit of a break I think it
took two years after breath of the wild
to announce this
game although I guess they did have
links Awakening in between as
well which was the same year 2019 so
yeah if it it's going to be something
small
probably why would the next direct be a
third-party direct though because every
direct that takes place in February or
January so sometimes it's either
or or actually it's or it's always in
January end of January or somewhere
beginning to mid-February that's always
been like the trend and it's always a
regular Direct it's never been a third
party direct
right maybe I'm wrong maybe they did do
that before
but oh I should have made a weapon that
is infused with
fire or lightning well well we got
arrows they shouldn't oversaturate the
franchise with tons of gain
too close together yeah as long as they
do not forget about 2del that because
that used to be the the thing to do like
in between the big 3D
releases I'm just tired of remakes and
ports and all that stuff I just want new
stuff that nobody has played
before Oh I got to do the
thing and then the Queen is g to oh I
got to fill up that quarter heart or
else I'm going to die in the first
minute all
right let's try
this actually I'm going to switch bows I
don't like the
Zoom watch the sand stream I forgot
everything about this boss pretty
much I forgot all the
patterns I just know at some point that
there's going to be hives like gibo
hives let's go we'll finish it all here
and there's just one thing I want to do
real quick like over
here I'm going to put a platform here so
I have something to Bullet time off of
we got it cornered here
we've got it
cornered oh my God this that that really
does hurt you're
right well there go goes our first meal
and my challenge to beat it without
getting
hit not that I expected to be able to do
that
but
it's
vulnerable
torado oh I got no
stamina at
all come on no not
yes
I think the first time it took me like
three
tries I'm just going to bombard it with
all the strong
stuff oh that's not a strong thing
that's just a
wing does this hurt actually not that
much she's not facing
me
oh my God I have no
stamina I have to stop running out of
stamina I know the first phase is pretty
easy I don't
need
uhoh oh my god oh
jeez I did not know she can do
that I keep
learning uh do I have anything else to
eat
apples just give me your
power oh oh my God there's no way I can
dodge
that I just don't have the mobility for
it
okay now it's going to get really
difficult cuz now we have to deal with
gios
too
give me your
power oh they're so fast they're so
they're so
creepy where's your
power okay there we
go oh that did not do
anything
oh the crawly ones are so
creepy oh oh no leave me
alone
no oh my
God killed by a
gibo well that's number
one
I wish you could just trigger her
ability I I wish they didn't do that you
have to actually walk up to
her oh you can actually Dodge it pretty
easily you're just an
idiot it would be it would be so much
better if you can just trigger it by
with like with a button just like all
your other other abilities why do you
have to walk up to them cuz the AI just
doesn't always want to work with you
having to rely on the AI is kind of I
don't know it's kind of
infuriating cuz sometimes she's she's
just fighting other enemies like on the
other side of the
room
maybe I I probably cannot Shield that
right can I just shoot her
with
this does that do anything oh it
does I don't need you reu for
this there we go
yeah who tested play tested the AI
thought it was was a good idea also if
you fight with multiple of the sages at
the same time you always trigger the
wrong one cuz everybody's it's Justa
pure chaos everybody's just running
through each
other oh God no
wrong what killed me
did I kill
myself did I kill myself by burning the
floor I I should have just ate food
right away when I got
hit oh this is going to be a tough
one stay away from
me
okay lesson learned I just got to heal
right
away the tornado every time I get hit I
just have to immediately heal R got
knocked on her
ass
maybe you should get some fairies no
that's
cheating this is Dark
Souls oh my god oh
yeah she going to do it again yeah this
time I saw it
coming no idea what happened
there wait where did my platform
go I should just not like leave it up to
chance I should always just immediately
eat even having a quarter heart of
damage gone is just
enough oh no
oh luckily I can freeze this FaceTime
Continuum to
eat in Dark Souls I would have been
already been screwed by
now can I destroy it
yes oh my God they really have a giant
hit box when they do that
jump should use the stakes the stakes
are
my
salvation stand in the
light why use the
mirror oh they get hurt by
that that's
brilliant
[Music]
oh they just die automatically you don't
even have to do
anything reu come
here oh jeez
epic
Dodge where are your sand boots I'm I'm
I have not done anything as I'm just
going straight from objective to
objective like I don't I have not
upgraded my armor I've not done any
shrines oh there it
comes
where's
reu
oh
oh ran out of
stamina look yourself
where did she fall down
oh reu get over
here think I can go in between these two
tornadoes
yeah
uh which one to use I think this is
one-handed one right oh no it's
two-handed I hate two-handed weapons
they're so
slow unless you do the spin I guess
that's I can do the
spin next time
no not enough stamina
again look
out yeah just activate your
thingy
let's go
reu wait why did she deactivate her
ability oh because she gets hit by the
tornado stop doing the
tornado
where did she go
oh let's
go
do your
thing where did she
go where did she
go oh
there
wait was that
it no right
oh
GG's two deaths not as much as I
thought same as my first playthrough
actually also took me three tries but I
had way more armor
than
yay thank you
bbop love the decorations on the wall
yeah they're pretty
neat they're pretty neat I like the
camos like there's clearly a Divine
Beast connection
there demon Stone secret
King hit the
cord there we
go Manda Stanton says speaking of deps
our former president died yesterday in a
helicopter crash
damn
rip that's
tough beloved of the gud secret King
demon
Stone I know that voice you're the one
who's been talking all this
time yes your ancestor from a Time long
past do you like my nose piering Warrior
who served the first king of hru and the
ring as you can I've seen you brandish
the power you have in defense of our
people I would expect nothing less from
my descendant you are the prde of the
good actually does she also say secret
Stone Demon kingon King is responsible
for sending the monster that calls the
sand
shroud but the monster's true purpose
was to prevent you from obtaining that
stone my secret
Stone Demon King
oh there we
go you will understand soon enough where
in the Netherlands do you live I live in
rotam or at least close to it the events
that shaped our people's Destiny during
the you can see them with no mask there
are videos online yeah I have the 3D
models not all of them have a face or
even a head some of them
do a great evil The Demon King emerged
you celebrating Carnival no that's more
like a South Netherlands thing like
braon
limber like the more rural provinces
they usually are big on Carnival I live
in what's called like the the
city Edge this the the big city
area the more populated area of the
Netherlands and we don't really have we
we do some of people do celebrate it or
they go to the RO rural provinces to
celebrate but it's not really a big
thing here yeah on
stop I just
call my ownr the populated area of the
Netherlands because most people live
along the coast for his overwheling like
South Holland North Holland those two
provinces they that's where most of the
live Ru knew we had the battle against
the demon king yeah
R I don't know what that really
translates
tooning City Ed Edge City Edge City I
don't know the imprisoning
war Kieran Buckley says I haven't been
to the Netherlands in almost 20 years
and it just rained the week I was there
well that doesn't really take a big
chance there's almost always rain
here even in summer you can have a
terrible few weeks here and there Autumn
is just rain rain rain spring is a mix
of the two also plenty of rain when that
time comes you must help I do have to
say this year has been especially bad
when it comes to
Raine like half of the summer was ruined
by
rain your power the G's control of
lightning so yeah no no surprise there
that when you visited here it happened
to
rain we wish nothing more than to
eliminate the Demon King we are
responsible for his very existence in
this world and for that we must make
amends I swear to you that when the
Demon King Returns the gudo siege of
lightning will awaken small also I will
not tell him you're a dragon sage and
because along your sword
reasons funny how none of the Zelda
stuff happens before she time traveled
into the past and now I yeah the time
travel in this game is really
weird it it it's almost like even the
characters themselves don't understand
it because raru also makes that mistake
where he's like well that that was a a
future where you didn't travel into the
past it's like but but the murals were
already there so
clearly don't
bre no I do not speak Spanish not very
well
noo so it's my destiny to fight by
that's all I can
say
my destiny as a sage my duties as
Chief to be fair half the sages would
eat their stones without a second
thought well at first I thought that was
going to be like a a thing maybe where
it turns out the sages also did the
thing and that's that explains the
dragons like the other three dragons but
[Music]
no
they're just other people who once did
something like
that I am theage of well I think they
covered them because it would spoil the
the the the plot
point but one of the
murals I'm pretty sure you can see the
sages including Zelda I'm not don't
quote me on that I'm I could be wrong
but I I thought one of them me
your but either way like the fact that
they recorded that part of history on
the
murals the whole idea like I thought
they were going to go for like a closed
time Loop stand but it's kind of wonky
the way it works to be fair like Zelda
has never done time travel all that well
there's always been plot holes here and
there things that just don't make sense
that like that conflict with each
other like I think in uh Skyward Sword
you can already see Zelda inside of the
crystal in the other room even though
that part of History hasn't happened yet
but she's already there but then at the
same time demise does live in the future
even though you're you kill him in the
past at some point so shouldn't like
those two things just don't work
together either deise is already dead in
the present because link will always go
to the to the past to kill him and
absorb him into the master sword or
Zelda should not be there like all those
things don't happen until he travels
into the past which is more like Back to
the Future where you can make actual
changes
she's not in well her modotto is not
inside the Amber I guess but I think
that is what they were going for but I'm
not
sure but there's multiple of those
little things also in arine of time
where the when you plant beans in the
past they show up like the the there's a
reason why the Song of Storms Paradox
exists of
course but time travel is really hard
there's so there's almost no movie or
game that does it perfect it's it's
incredibly difficult because you know
time travel is so intangible to our own
reality if time travel would exist in
our reality we don't even know how it
would work like every time you changed
things in the past will it will it just
create a separate reality or will it
actively start changing things in our
timeline you
know I didn't collect the heart I can
just go
back besides it's still a challenge run
I
guess I really did hope there was not
going to be any time travel in this game
because I'm kind I'm just getting sick
of it you know it doesn't always have to
have time
travel sometimes you can also write a
story without it and I guess maybe if
age of Calamity didn't do it or just
didn't come out at all it would have
maybe it would have been
different
but because age of Calamity already did
time travel in it in its story and now
we do it again I don't know I I guess I
just have time travel
fatigue I think they should skip the
time travel stuff for for a couple of
games or if they are going to put time
travel in it just do it like Skyward
Sword did with the the time shift stones
or like the Temple of Time in Twilight
Princess where it's just more
local like the it's not like part of the
bigger
plot hey monster everyone we talking
about tears of the Kingdom in tears of
the kingdoms inconsistent time travel
yeah just time travel travel in general
in the series
has never been done
perfect but in in this game it
especially confuses
me I'm I'm still not sure what they were
going for whether raru just made a
mistake by saying that the future that
they had like that was before she tra
like traveled back in time
because how would that
work honestly like how would that work
wouldn't she always end up doing the
time travel thing because it makes all
kinds of things
possible and the fact that there is a
great
Calamity like that there's a Calamity
Ganon in breath the
wild is because they sealed Ganon below
hyu castle that's his Gloom leaking out
and creating Calamity Ganon
so that is the result of something that
happened in the ancient past already
which we now know is something Zelda was
a part of so she would always she was
always destined to go to the
past but
then they also kind of imply that the
light dragon kind of popped into
existence out of nowhere as soon as she
traveled back in time but shouldn't she
always be up there like for the whole
like millions and millions of years that
since the ancient past thing happened
she should have so there's technically
two Master
swords at all times the one in the
forest and the one that got taken back
in
time like at least breath Dell didn't
have time travel so yeah it it was a a
much easier story to comprehend this one
I'm not too sure I'm not even sure how
to write it into my script for my video
because it's it's so difficult to
unravel what exactly it is that they
were going
for I think that Ru was just guessing or
being optimistic okay yeah I yes that's
possible I just want to know what
exactly it is that they were going for
that's all uh cuz I don't want to just
say oh the time travel makes no sense
because if I'm just understanding it
wrong then that's not fair to this game
because there's already so many issues I
have with this story without the time
travel in mind so you
know I do want to be fair at least oh I
still have to collect the hard piece
damn
it we need another developer interview
yeah well the fact that they have to
explain all kinds of things in hindsight
during interviews is kind of weird to
me
like I I appreciate them trying to help
us understand a bit
better but it should not be
necessary if you have to explain all
kinds of things
later to me at least that shows that you
didn't do your story you you didn't
write your story very
well
unless it's like one of those types of
stories where you have to like interpret
the meaning of the story for
yourself which that that's not really
what this story is in my opinion it's
not really that kind of
story heart piece or hard
[Music]
container they hyped up secret Stones
yet it seems that only Ganondorf secret
Stone really matters it beats six others
breaking the mass sword well I guess
that that's kind of because he was
already powerful like insanely like way
more powerful than the others because I
do think they say that the stones
amplify your all like they they only
amplify your gifts they don't really do
anything if you're not already
powerful hello looks like I missed the
boss battle says snooze boo yeah it went
okay two deaths
one
suicide I shot an arrow into the
floor with only a quarter of heart left
and I guess the burn damage got to
me just wish the wild era could have a
story that takes place in the present I
don't know why tears of the Kingdom
Story made made me feel like I'm outside
looking Within
I want to I want to know so much more
about the Zone ey
yeah yeah it's kind of crazy
how a game that was hyping up the Zone
ey and it was all about oh we're going
to finally see the Zone ey and we're
going to what do we actually learn about
the Zone I not that much aside from what
they look
like but we don't know much about their
civilization why they went extinct what
happened to
them
like I do think something in the
Japanese version says something about
them just dying
out but even that I'm not too sure I
just wish
they put in like they didn't have to
show the whole zonai civilization at its
peak but they could have at least put in
a little bit more environmental
storytelling what because the The Sky
Islands don't tell us much they don't
tell us anything
really it's kind of
empty it's a couple of buildings that
don't
really resemble
anything give me your
fruit I probably should not go here yet
CU I don't have flame resistant
anything
now that I think about
it I'm going to burn to death oh no wait
the the lava is gone of course I'm so
used to breath the wild just catching
fire immediately once you go onto Death
Mountain Z ni Sky
dwellers well we don't even know if the
sky islands were like their main CU it
seems like they populated hyu for a
while
there's just not enough you know there's
not enough information to work with when
it comes to the environment itself like
there's no Island up there
that gives off any hint of a village for
example it's all just small little gray
Shrine type of
buildings nope I'm not going to make it
and I'm going to
ow oh wait I'm here I'm in the
mine that's actually a good place to
be
good day
sir and now you're just a normal like
like
I do like the like likes I do like the
like likes in this game I think they're
pretty
cool are you going to do the fire temple
on stream now uh no probably not the
whole I I don't think we're going to get
there before cuz I don't want to ruin my
sleep sleeping schedule too much
actually can I get rid of a shield no
well this one is actually kind of
useless s Shield is
better right oh no it's Rusty shield
never
mind I don't like the rusty
Shield but for me it's already getting
closer to midnight so I I guess we can
at least do some stuff in Goron City and
be on our way to the
depths but the fire temple is definitely
for the the
weekend now that I'm pretty much better
we can
uh we can finally beat it the
only exception is if I'm going to get my
video done then I might do it on
Monday because I am working on a video
the the first video of the the Year I
hope to get that one up on
Sunday going to do my very
best so and obviously that's more
important to get a new video up
so if it ends up complet in with the
stream I'll just move the stream one or
two days but I I'll let you guys
know yeah yeah I am doing the the fire
temple again on stream we' we've done it
before like way back
when but we might as well just finish
most of the
game because I still have to record
record
stuff
oh heat
resistance oh that's still from that's
still the last buff I got from my
fight uh uh uh
uh do I have anything left to E I will
quickly take a bathroom break before we
do
anything in Goron
City the fire temple stream was the
first one you watched oh yeah that one
was that was a fun
stream I think I
was like also capturing
footage I like how the music is all
weird
keep your hands off of that oh my
God but I want
it actually we're going to have to grind
for rupes again CU I need the uh heat
resistant
armor I'm I'm disappointed in the
gorons drugs are never the
[Music]
answer
yeah Gore on drug addicts yeah
wavery says I got to try and get some
sleep later y'all have a good time yeah
you too have a good
sleep sleep is
important at least for
me all right I am going to run
downstairs real quick I will be back in
two or three minutes going to grab some
water and
then I will be
back uh yeah I will put just put it on
the waiting
screen be be right back
BRB will will be right H what was I
thinking will be right back as if it's a
freaking
broadcast oh well I'll be right back
for
e
I am
back yeah
let's
go uh I think we can
just can we just immediately go to the
headquarters or we have to talk to
someone here
first oh here they
are look at that
guy I'm tripping balls
man
he the aliens from maor's mask should
100% come
back yeah that that was a fun little
mystery they're not the same as the the
zai for sure but they
are but
also would they come back to Hyrule this
time or is it like a maurus like are
native
determiner there's to worry about in my
opinion now stop flapping your rock
Chompers and get over here
Goro
Goro the moment you noo became
Heisenberg what could you
want say my
name you no Co you noo
Co you're God damn
[Music]
right I miss Breaking
Bad was such a good
watch but I'm glad they finished it they
ended it on a high
note as opposed to The Walking Dead just
keep going and going until everyone's
just sick of
it but that was also just the writer's
fault they made some big mistakes after
season
six
changed
yeah oh shoot I'm still
recording I don't have to record this
part I already got
it luckily I do have to map for
this is better call Sol done
yeah one season more than Breaking Bad
was six seasons also very
good it's more uh
uh I guess it's less eventful than
Breaking Bad but like in its own way
it's also very very
good some even prefer it over breaking
bad I thought it was very good but I do
still think Breaking Bad was
better G
theia suddenly they all know about
gandia gandia is a legendary place where
the gorens of old used to live see
that's another one of those things like
I really like the idea of a big
underground city but the fire temple
doesn't really feel like a city you know
what I mean it like there's no housing
there's
no there's no place where you would
think that this is where people used to
live
they could have done a better job of
like the the snow peak ruins for example
that place really felt like a place
where people used to
live Twilight prin has had such oh great
dungeons wait what's
happening that's my card wait
what really oh my God this
kid oh my God this kid you
are fine I'll you use my own card
then what if he said that that that like
he does the same thing that's also my
card don't don't use
it
wait oh my
God that's not his card that was my
card is it because I shot
him fine we'll just walk oh my God this
kid is really getting on my
nerves I'm going to take out my
frustration on this Coro
I feel like justice has been done here
today well he was asking for that bomb
Arrow come
on there's more important matters than
his little stupid cart there's tons of
carts there's carts
everywhere I even ow I even went through
the effort
of taking a different card he just
claims all of
them because you shot at him you don't
have any bombs uh we'll we'll get new
ones in the
depth actually we should go to the depth
at some
point mine some
stuff let me guess 700
bucks and I don't think I have much to
sell buy something will
you
yeah this is uh this is going to be
rough only two bucks for GTO guts
really still can't sell
these only have one of
these these are all lowlevel fuse
anyway yeah um I'm guessing we're going
to just have to mine for some stuff
later before we actually go there
uh let's just go to Yobo real
quick can also do the spirit Temple
first oh there's a crap is right there
actually to the
deps uh wait where is the headquarters
again oh we're already there oh it's
there there we
go we have to fight
Yobo
you
Noble
minu comedy drum sound I I actually am
wondering if we can get to minu in our
current state because I did not upgrade
my zonea battery at
all nor my stamina so I don't think the
weeo is going to save us
I guess they're just tied up in their
rib cage yeah that's actually true where
do the guts come
from link has minu with him in the purad
right now yeah he sure
does and she does not explain why she
did okay so
ah yeah off to the depths we go we're
just going to see if we can get to menu
uh we also need to activate one more
Tower here so yeah we're definitely not
going to do the fire temple anytime
soon I get I guess I could buy a fire
like buy one of those fireproof Elixir
but I mean we have to get the outfit at
some point
anyway yeah she actually says she wanted
to Aid him from from the start but then
doesn't explain why uh at
all it was the upheaval just blame the
upheaval yeah she she literally says uh
I was planning to wake up earlier and
they're like
but and why didn't you and she just
doesn't say anything she does not
elaborate at
all at first I thought well you do you
have to do the spirit temple in order to
awake her but she herself admits that
she could have woken up at any moment to
help
him in general minu is like kind of like
a walking plot hole to begin
with
uh cuz she also knows that Zelda is a
dragon but she doesn't tell
you she knows that she was planning to
do it she she wasn't there she was
already in the pad when she
transformed but I mean she there's
literally a scene of the two together
where she outlines her plan to
her so she definitely
knew
100% she justes doesn't want to tell you
she
forgot like this is like the
main thing
like where is
it find Princess Zelda this is the
equivalent of defeat
Ganon it's the big big main plot point
of the whole
story The Sage is
New minu New
yeah I I like minu as a character that
that's the problem like there was
definitely potential there I like minu I
like Sonia a lot I I like to an extent I
do like raru even though he's a bit of
an idiot but I I like his character
design I like his
personality it's just that the writing
is kind of weak and it just it's such a
shame because they really did have
something going for
them when it came to the
actual like they had the set pieces down
they had the characters
down all they needed is good writing to
tie it all
together cuz your characters can
be amazing but if their choices don't
really make sense then there's going to
be a
disconnect yeah it would have been cool
if they tied min to the ancient shika
somehow in general the zonai and the
shika connection
is a bit underdeveloped cuz clearly it
was inspired by
it like the Divine beasts are literally
designed we see these designs in the
zonai dungeons in this
game but then technically should the
shika know about Ganondorf being trapped
below the
castle normally they're pretty good at
passing down knowledge so why didn't
they
we oh luckily this one can just be
activated I don't have to wait oh no I
guess not
it's not
working something needs to be
done we get some
herbs so what's up with this Tower
then
uh
something going
down go down the
well all
right also does anyone feel like the
wells are a little bit
underutilized like I really love the
idea of a well but they're basically
just caves just like any other
and now I wish I didn't waste that bomb
arrow on the Goron
kid I don't think this can break it
right no you need a
boulder I don't think I have
anything well that sure came back to
bite me in the
butt I don't have zai time bombs
either yeah I know fuse a rock but
there's no Rock here right or are these
two oh these are I thought these were
part of the
scenery yeah
okay uh do I want to keep this one or I
guess we'll just
unfuse the
weak the weak
version
oh now they give me a bomb flower those
bastards just to rub it
in sup
buddy could you just help me what's
wrong I cannot move the camera
in
there was one well that was a lot more
extensive by the grudo Highland
stable yeah there's a couple that are
decent but I I really hoped they were
going to be more like creepy mini mini
dungeons but they just look like all the
other caves
mostly I feel like they could have done
a little bit more with them because
right now it's just caves and Wells are
almost indistinguishable from from each
other they're just the same
so I gotta find an whoa that was a big L
lag Spike
uh what's going on
again yeah so there is a cave entrance
there
okay I got in that way okay so it's up
up
there like imagine if every well was
more of a kind of
like well like I said like more like a
creepy mini dungeon that is a little bit
longer and the reward is a
bit like the reward is actually worth
it CU there's caves too that also have
pretty
good like uh they they have
pretty like they they have ruins in them
some of them like the the ancient grudo
prison for
example where did this guy come
in somewhere around
here
no
B bottom of the well dungeon get ready
for nightmares
yeah where where's this cave entrance
he's talking
about I should have it's actually weird
that there's no map for the underground
cave area only for the
depth is it somewhere around here it has
to be here somewhere
right is it here oh that might be
it I hope this is the same cave yeah it
is
bloopy oh we do need money
though what if I just let him sit
there I probably need him for a puzzle
or
something H roll's economy of suffering
yeah 50 bucks we're already on the way
on our way like
17 or
almost so he's going to fix the tower
okay
okay does that one also open up when you
press this no
nope can I
just
yeah dragon skills also sell for a lot
as well yeah but get to the dragons is a
bit of a pain right now CU I don't have
a lot of
stamina apparently the heart of a
fearsome lion demon is only worth 200
bucks you mean Lal guts
or yeah that's actually not that much
considering how tedious like the those
fights consume so many
resources like you go through half your
weapons at
least at least for the for the later
ones
[Music]
still crazy that this game runs on the
switch as well as it
does considering the seamlessness
between the sky The Depths and the the
[Music]
surface they really got the the engine
they nailed it when it comes to the
engine how are we feeling about Zelda's
future after tears of the Kingdom
uh unpredictable I would
say because you know the nobody expected
wind waker after AR of time and maor's
mask so there's no way of knowing what
will happen next and that's good that's
good good
good I think that's how it should
be it's what keeps this series relevant
the fact that they keep mixing it
up H we're not going to make that no
way no way unless I have something
stamina no
oh we
do
I hope I can make
this actually I can
just go through
here I think I only have zai stuff CRA
crab we eating
crab the crab saved us
man it's really
really dark
here yeah I don't think I have anything
metal on
me so this one is
not th this one is this one is
not so I guess I'll use this
one the zai Shield is
fine and this one is fine too okay we're
good we're going
golden and the visibility here oh well
there goes my my
weapon oh jeez did that tree just got
knock knocked
down I have no idea where to
go it's so
dark I can barely see the edge of every
island just because of the
raindrops I see something
there man this is going to be difficult
to
navigate and I have no
map
wait oh this one
is uh this one
then
yeah so we're doing the spirit Temple
already well I'm not sure if we're going
to be doing the whole Spirit Temple
today we can at least get to mino's
island okay I just saw lightning strike
there so there should be Solid Ground I
also see a
robot
dude I did this the right way the first
time or the the intended way I should
say off you
go I guess we're just going to have to
wait for lightning to strike somewhere
to see if we can
[Music]
advance man the visibility is horrible
here
I'm guessing the stream quality is not
really
great because of all the particles
and uh oh there is ground beneath here
as well maybe I can try
to shoot one of these is there something
there no
how about
there I don't even know how people did
this the first
time guess we're just going to have to
take a leap of
faith I have no more
crab
oh
no oh it stopped raining oh there's a
ledge
here oh please make
it oh no it starts raining
again how about using reu oh
maybe maybe her ability will trigger
it
oh what the hell read you or ghost
reu oh that kind of yeah that kind of
works
yeah you sir are a
genius uh-oh uhoh
okay where did you give me
some give me some
Intel yeah this actually
works it's like playing virtual reality
let's
go
uh I think I still have a zai
platform I still got 10 of
them I like doing things the way that
like the hard way the convolute
way uhoh is that
a wow I don't know how how I got that
head shot re
you where is he there he
is I will not who there he
goes I was about to say I'm not going to
let this whz Rob ruin my perfect run of
this
island
no where are we on the map now okay so
here here is the
head I forgot if the head is lower or
higher I think it's
lower like it's below all the other
Island stuff
here
hey okay it's safe to go
here don't you need 10 Hearts to open
the door oh my God you got to be well we
can at
least oh it is lower
okay I guess we can try to make
it but with this stamina though we can
at least activate the shrine there so we
can always get back
there actually who was the one who told
me to to use ru's magic powers to see
that is actually
brilliant it's really making this work
oh you can skip the door
uhoh
goodbye isn't this
fun
do I have anything to make stamina stuff
from oh a Stam bulb we have a Stam
bulb but do we have anything to mix it
with that doesn't have any effects of it
of its
own we're out of
apples
this one has its own well we got rock
salt and
wood but that's definitely going to make
dubious food and
oil it's very versatile and cooking and
C flavors from ingredients used in many
dishes also for adding fuel to
fire will a zonai cooking pot work here
since it's
raining I guess they they
do you need to be precise to skip the
door is it like a a cheat like a glitch
CU if that's the case I don't want to I
don't really want to do
it that just doesn't feel Fair
I'll just have to do some shrines next
time or
something oh there's something
here wooden
planks so it should be is that it there
I think I can see a silhouette over
there we got extra stamina not much like
barely not even a quarter
it isn't really a glitch just using
Ascend in a clever way okay then it's
then it's fine like if it's an actual
like
clip all right we'll just we're just
going to go for
it give me the we
woo I think that might be
it
oh I hope we can make
this are we already
[Music]
yes I just need to have like safe place
to land please
oh
no wait maybe it will it will spawn me
here I hope it will no it
doesn't we'll just jump right
away at least we still have the the
stamina thingy epic gamer moment I
couldn't see the
floor oh we're going to have to do this
part
again
you have a death marker
yeah that's true so we know it's here
somewhere but it's like a whole island
chain I think oh there there's the whz
Rope thingy
again uhoh
ow I should probably heal up shouldn't
I
oh that's Link's reaction when he dies
oh
do I have to take out another one oh
wait it gives it back to me because it
resets you too before you use
it now I lost my death
marker total deaths
10 still satisfied with that wait I did
I I did have Full Hearts how did it kill
me is it because of the status
effect oh just go
away Oh my
Jesus oh I hate whis ropes so
much they're the worst you know what I'm
just going to try to try to get
there oh but I didn't cook the stamina
thingy though oh let's hope this works
actually I can save up on a little bit
of stamina by Falling I
guess come on give me the
weoo
see because there's a few separate
Islands
here and if I fall in between
those I am
screwed
oh we hit Solid Ground now let's
save yeah
yeah we
woo now where do we
enter is it in
here oh I see a spiral
thingy
yes
woo oh the music here is so good
so
good now the fun begins yeah someone uh
has to point out to me how you get past
the door
I have nothing to
offer absolutely
nothing but you do not have nope I did
not do any Shrine I did one it
seems I think you go under the sky
[Music]
island all right let's try let's let's
just see we don't have a map to orient
ourselves below where we should be but
we can at least
investigate you have to use the glider
to fly under the island and then
Ascend but you cannot Ascend while
gliding is there is there an island
below
here oh no there goes the visibility
again I thought maybe because we
activated the shrine the visibility
would be
okay no tool in God damn it
okay this is going to be impossible
without a map oh you have to use a zonai
glider I don't think I have any of those
oh I do I have
[Music]
one but then from
which let me see read you give me some
Intel is there an island nearby that I
can at least stand
on come on there has to be like a small
little island nearby that I can use as
a or I can use floating platforms I
guess use
scope this thing
oh I can see hyro
castle that's not what I wanted to do
but oh there there is a separate little
island
here I think this is not part of the
itself but how am I going to Glide all
the way under
there like that would have to be very
very
precise but you know even if if we do
fail at
least we got the uh the Fast Travel
point so we can just
try I can try using zonai platforms
first CU I'm not very good at
controlling the glass
GL the only thing I'm a bit worried
about
is oh well there we go that that ends
our adventure right
there
well I just uh I'm just going to hang
out here
over over on this part for a
while
oh it's so close it's right
there right
here what if the zonai platform combined
with an
arrow well or something that can push it
Forward oh
well I don't think there's anything uh
to hold on to
here
nah I guess we'll just warp back to this
point
then it's weird when you're inside the
island the visibility becomes good again
and then for a brief moment when you
like
resurface then is visibility but then it
immediately
dissipates we're just going to solve
this right here right
now see like there is visibility right
now and then as soon as
I get out of
this the visibility will be
bad but yeah it's I can use a scope to
make a pin I guess
yeah I guess that's what the other
person meant sorry I wasn't
checking the chat the whole time
but
no I want it
here okay so we know where a oh it goes
away when you get to it that's
nice I did not tell them to do
that again again just
disappears okay so about
there where's
Ru I love how difficult we're making
this I could just do a couple of shrines
get some hearts but
no
H what's that down there is that the
landing
platform or no
oh wait yeah there's something
here
I like playing Zelda games this
way do you think I could just or will I
just get to the island above cuz it is
inside here
somewhere let me just save here then we
can always reload this
area if you get to the right spot you'll
lose the pin yeah I can at least just
Ascend real quick to see what's up there
if if we actually get inside of a room
or or if we just emerge on top of the
island yeah this is just the top of the
island so we do need to go
lower oh there's a Pinko machine here or
whatever it's called gumball
machine I don't think this will work
either that would be way too
easy yeah we have to go lower for
sure all right is pin still there yeah
it
is I guess we could try using those
platforms
now if we put one
there let's at least
try cuz the glider I don't think I can
get the glider to move that
way
because there's no real point from which
I
can launch
it it will probably not make
it it would be fun if we actually solve
this unless you put fans on the
glider
yeah I also have a glider inside my uh
inventory
where are the gliders
here is this it oh there's Rockets here
o can we use a rocket
platform let's try the glider first
though I I really don't have much
battery though
so
like I have very very little battery so
this is going to only be able
to let me check real quick what happens
when you this is how you control it and
then you press B immediately have Ascend
ready so I'm controlling I'm flying it
and then immediately
just all
right oh this is going to be so
difficult
well I need a launch point because I
really don't have the batteries to go
very like if I have to make a U-turn for
like while flying this dire because
obviously the track is right
here this is the jump off point normally
but we're pretty far from that pin so if
I have to make a uturn that
way like we're going to go that way that
way first and then make a u-turn I don't
think my battery is going to allow cuz
it's two
fans and a control
thingy I think that's going to run out
really really really
quickly I don't think one fan is enough
I don't think you can steer it with only
one
fan I hope it takes off from like from
this
point if I put it here there was a
little Gap here
somewhere
okay hey thank you Hector for the Super
Chat love your love you dude your work
is astounding truly thank you so much
that means that means a lot
yeah see it
doesn't it it doesn't take off from here
I have to either like inch it across
like until it loses its balance and then
jump on it really
quickly which I guess we can
do no oh oh
oh
no oh my God we're going so fast
no
no where's the
pin no we're not going to make
it so I can only inch it like a little
bit okay so now I just have to accept
this okay we are going the right
direction
though
oh it won't let me go
higher
recall
okay that's actually pretty
smart but will it get us to the point to
where we need to go though at least it
charges my battery for a while
oh why won't this thing just go
higher it's more that way that that that
way
we're just going to endlessly recall
this
thing you need the hover bike yeah
true this thing doesn't really have any
upward momentum at
all I guess it's that little thing over
there but I don't think we can get close
enough to it
no oh and it's also losing its uh juice
how do you make a hover bike again I
know there's a
way like very easy way wait let's load
our last save real
quick yeah I guess we did get pretty
close hover bike doesn't work oh yeah
cuz it will just drop down the moment
you let go of the uh the
throttle I guess platforms it is
then I guess we really do have to use
platforms I can at least see where these
Rockets take me
[Music]
uh but wait as soon as I activate this
thing the rocket will immediately take
it
somewhere
somewhere so I don't think this is going
to work
either
I would have to just just chain multiple
platforms but I don't think you can pull
out a platform while you're on a Zone ey
platform can't you just Glide under and
shoot a zonai
platform fuse to an arrow you can do
that how does that
work I'm curious how how does that work
what happens when you
fuse oh wait no you cannot do
that
right platform plus
arrow but like fuse it to what draw my
bow and
then
I really don't know what you
mean up
Arrow like with the fire fruit but there
is
no Oh you mean
just
no oh you I get I got you I didn't know
they the zonai devices showed up here
when you draw your bow that's actually
but what happens when you do
this does it just does it stop at some
point or does it just just keep
going where is
it
let me shoot one
here oh just kind of
stops what happened to the other
one oh it's there oh I you can see it
actually but it's already running out of
battery so I might as well do another
like another
try
I did not know that that actually
works that's pretty
awesome oh the other the other platform
is still going
too I did not know you can fuse a
platform to your to your bow that's
that's awesome they really thought of
everything didn't
they yeah you have to be quick for sure
and I have to know where to jump that
that's probably the biggest
issue Glide to the point then fuse the
platform and point
downward oh I gotta you can just shoot
it straight down and then immediately
land on
it I'm telling you doing crap like this
is what makes this game fun yeah for
sure uh okay so the pin is over there
approximately let's just go for it let's
just try
it oh
oh I didn't fuse
it no it doesn't show up right below you
okay
reload oh I think we we do have our
method now
though I think this is the way to
go this is the
way this is the way
all because of that stupid
door okay let's try
again okay so let me
just oh it doesn't save
it okay now it does default to it okay
[Music]
uh we got to hit the
edge oh
no let me just practice this real
quick how do you make that actually
no not save
load shoot Slightly North you you really
have to shoot it and then immediately
pull out your paraglider or also doesn't
you you don't have enough momentum to
actually make it
there your PIN is at the door not the
room no I put the pin on the little
grade I I think the pin is in the right
spot cuz the grate is a little bit
behind where I went
up
oh
okay I don't think we're high enough
though now if only I had a rocket
to do you think a fan would work do you
think a fan would take us higher or does
that
not
is it doing
anything I don't think it's doing
anything ah that that's a shame only I
guess only rockets
work
I just have to be even more quick it's
because I keep clamping onto the wall it
like when you're clamped onto a wall and
you you release you you let go of the
wall there's like a cool down where you
cannot immediately pull out your
paraglider
no I want that
one so I just I have to try not to
get stuck to the wall so I just have to
drift down for a little bit first but
it's so hard to anticipate when the wall
is coming oh there it
is this high enough
no it's right
there can I just pull out another
platform
let's see if that
works no maybe if I inch
myself
no can I shoot another platform I don't
know if that's
straight I make that
no
oh I'm almost out of battery no not not
even close you cannot really determine
where where it shows up it just kind of
does oh I that's not what I wanted ah I
over actually I can reposition the pin
just to make sure I
guess
you can do it I believe in you this
looks so hard it's probably not hard for
people who actually are good at the game
I just really
suck I don't play this game enough like
Croton would do it in like one try no
doubt so like see here's the
door and I put the pin here on on the
grade so that should do
it
yeah now to get back to that platform
where we
were was down here
somewhere
was it
here where was
it is it
here shoot I don't remember where it
was H I don't remember where it was does
anyone
know I wish I
didn't I shouldn't have overridden my
save so
stupid look a
gly I am not sleeping until we get this
done this damn door needs to
be
conquered I hate this door
reload your old save and go to the well
I accidentally over I've like I've
overwritten my my
save it was somewhere like to the left
like
slightly
it's
somewhere
here somewhere around
here you could see it
before none of this would have been
necessary if I
just didn't override my
save
oh yeah there we
go all right we're
back
okay we can also just try to shoot a few
see how far we get shoot a few
platforms like at the same level
approximately
just uh like see where we end
up I only got eight of them
but although that will drain my battery
really really quickly I methinks so I
would have to shoot down the last one to
save up on
batteries where's the other platform
oh there it
is I hate durability I really hope they
get rid of
it okay where are we
going oh no I overshot
it oh no
ah I'm out of
batteries no don't
save
load recycle
arrows collect arrows
Zai
charges oh I can eat sonai charges right
like I don't know if you eat them
but sonai
charges you don't really eat them right
use okay that would be funny though I
mean link won't eat anything so it's
actually well within his
character and I can do that from the
pause menu so yeah that's actually
pretty
good it's just so hard to see where
you're
going
uh should I try no we we should just try
to get get there
right the more batteries I'm or the more
platforms I'm creating the
more where is it where is it okay
the more quickly my battery will
drain he where are we on the
map I think we might need one
more no no no no no no no no no we're
not going to do
that why does he clamp onto the
wall you bastard but we we have a we
have a I think this is our best plan so
far I do think I have to get rid of the
previous platform to save up on battery
life maybe unless we can somehow do it
with three maybe
four yeah we could this is doable it is
it
is it's just landing on these things is
so
difficult without with the limited
visibility oh my
God
oh I can make yellow
battery I can make yellow
battery okay we we're already
there oh
no okay plan of attack here we're below
we're right below the room but we're
still too high
up you have large zai charges no we used
it
against an enemy before go further down
you sure because
as soon as I get past the
pin that's when we emerge from outside
the door still like the door is right
look like right behind the pin even less
like somewhere around
here but there
is let me just
check
is reu here with me
no where did I put the
platform maybe I should put another one
just to be
sure oh my
God
no it won't let
me where are we we're right
there I guess we're just barely
underneath some wall or
something it won't let me do the
thing
do you think you have to be further
down do you need to be past this wall
maybe but then we are really like right
below the
pin oh please don't let me down
okay no still
not
is it too
steep
please where are
we we're
inside is that the
great we did
it
[Laughter]
we got
this
woo my my beonce is probably thinking
downstairs like what the hell is he
doing I never get this excited when I
play video
games not vocally
anyway we cheesed it I couldn't have
done it without you guys you your your
suggestions made this possible
I never knew you could shoot
platforms and the zonai charges that was
a brilliant one too that one saved
us Z's like that those were the two key
in ingredients for this one it was the
the zai charges and the the
platforms because only the platforms
wouldn't have done it because there's we
just don't have the battery for
it the moment I saw that cursor turned
green I was like like my heart
jumped
okay so I
guess
uh let me just save just to be
sure yeah we all did it my horrible
controls or my horri gaming
skills like the visibility was probably
what killed me the most it's just it's
so hard to
see it's really easy to overshoot
it I don't think I need
it
well I could actually just to be sure so
I can at least control it a little
bit well that was much a much more fun
adventure than the actual dungeons or
story sometimes you have to create your
own fun not the fun that the developers
intended
oh wait I forgot the steering wheel
thingy Peak gaming
moment this is going to go in the on the
the
highlights actually which highlights I
don't really I'm not a gaming bod
channel uh oh I think we're gonna hit
that
rock I grant you this gift thank you so
much
W ver
W it may be dangerous but you are not
alone well done monster B well thank you
so much again this was a group effort
for
sure
I guess we're just going to crash into
this
wall
who Mino
uh just going to put you
down like the whole plot hole about minu
uh like they could have solved
that just by having her spirit be inside
this thing instead of inside the
uh the purad because that then it would
have made sense you
know of course then there's the question
of why would she be inside the mask
thingy but still at least it would have
made sense why she didn't awaken
earlier hope you like the depths oh yeah
we have to go to the depths now that's
the first time going into the depths I
think
um unless we went there like for a brief
second I guess we'll find out because
you do get like a little prompt that
tells you you're inside the
depths which doesn't happen anymore once
you
do to safeguard herself like th and
Robbie separating after the Calamity
yeah for example they could have made
that work like she just put her soul
into this
thing that would have made sense the
fact that it's inside the purad is what
kind of killed
it but uh thanks once again
W for a Super
Chat very awesome of you very
generous
elevator sorry I'm eating a
mandarin
link Zelda's chosen
protector you must hurry we must meet as
soon as possible we must meet you're
right
here I know she's like I have to have a
body made for me that that makes
sense as a spirit she's kind of useless
she cannot do
much but she can
talk which means she can at least
already explain herself
for for the most
part they really let you tackle the game
in whichever order sorry order and
Method you want that's probably the
game's greatest achievement yeah yeah
yeah for
sure that part of the nonlinearity is
where it
shines I guess the weaker part of the
nonlinearity is the
uh yeah this is the first time going
into deps but I like I I guess the
weaker part of the nonlinearity is the
way they tell the story but they can
overcome that in the next Zid
game uh oh isn't there like a thingy
here I can activate
to get back here
later oh yeah there's a light route let
me do that one
first because I don't think we're going
to do the whole SP Spirit Temple it's
like
it's 20 minutes after midnight here I
really do have to get to sleep
soon but this was fun this was a lot of
fun this is probably the most fun I've
had on the stream so far when it when it
comes to this
game oh yeah thank you
Hector till when will you stream uh well
we're probably G
to stop it pretty much
here and then we just uh do the spirit
Temple next
time and then the the the gorons after
that we'll mine some stuff in the depths
as well sell some
stuff because if I keep going my brain
is going to be Super Active before I go
to bed and then I I cannot fall asleep I
have to at least spend an hour or so
away from the computer to let my brain
like
stop back in the day I used to remedy
that by just reading just go to bed and
read there's it's such a big difference
if you're staring at a screen or if
you're staring at a page like an actual
object boom you've got a
head but yeah we'll we'll probably
stream on Monday I think I think Monday
a Monday stream would be the best
option unless somehow I managed to get
my video like done early
ear but they
usually uh recommend you don't stream
and upload on the same day because the
algorithm gets thrown off like it
doesn't know which one to prioritize to
push notifications for we can speak each
other so usually you try to do keep
those two separate without uh on
separate days cannot face so I am going
to upload on Sunday for sure so let's
just say let's just put it on Monday for
now Monday
stream with a
possible delay to Tuesday if for some
reason my video needs one more day
to to finish I would ask you to visit
each of them and assemble a body for me
but we'll see we'll see I'll keep you
guys up to up to date there will be two
streams for sure now that I'm better I I
do want to keep that going this is my
request to you link loyal swordsman to
Zelda and then next week on Wednesday
once
again I want to keep that discipline and
keep the keep the stream
running once you lose momentum that's
when you're starting that that's when it
starts to sneak in and
you're cuz that that that kind of been
my problem before I would only stream
once in a while so you don't get into a
rhythm of streaming
so there would be just huge gaps where I
just don't feel like streaming or I'm
kind of out of it for a
while uh but yeah thank you all so much
for uh for joining me on this crazy
adventure and uh yeah we did
it we can uh safely continue our
adventure without stupid doors I guess
the only thing
that's kind of in our way now is the
master sword because you need more
stamina for that one actually you don't
really you can just face Ganondorf and
it when when he does his second phase or
third or fourth I don't even know when
he becomes a dragon you just get the
master sword anyway so I guess you can
beat Ganondorf without the master
sword so yeah let's just try that
what what was supposed to be just a
quick like hey let's just go through the
main story record some footage for my
upcoming video it turned into a crazy
wild challenge
run but yeah thank you all for joining
and uh I will see you very very soon
again uh oh got to find the off but
all right thank you so much for joining
and see you next time
byebye